Cory you say if you can't answer this
one question your script will be
rejected yes
um true
story I broke in the business by selling
a pitch to Really Scott called
Metropolis when I was in film school and
then uh I was flown to London to work
with Ridley to flesh out the the story
before I go to write it so it was really
crazy I mean I'm in film school and then
I'm on a plane flying first class which
I didn't not even not only have I never
flown first class I didn't know it
existed and this is how dumb I am they
were coming by like food and alcohol and
I was like no no cuz I can't afford any
of that and then when I was in London
someone was like you don't pay for that
in first class we paid for it and I'm
like so I ate really well on the way
home but anyway so I'm in London and I'm
just like my big thing is I don't want
really to realize I'm a student and I
don't know what I'm doing and I just
don't want to get fired the first day I
want to survive one day before I get
fired I was very freaked out so I go
into the meeting I'm just trying to act
like I belong uh I don't feel like I do
but I'm trying really Scott's a hero of
mine anyway we come down to business and
he's like so uh Metropolis what's it
about so I give him like the the the
plot overview you know like if you're
flipping through your DVR and there was
like a description and he said oh yeah
yeah um when what I mean is like what's
it really about like at its core what's
it about and I remember going two
thoughts like oh boy I'm done like I no
one taught me this in film school I'm
not even sure what he's asking and then
the other thing is like to just look
confident because I was doing a lot of
improv at the time like look confident
and give an answer so I'm like oh oh
that's what you mean and I gave him an
answer and he's like oh that's
interesting but what do you think it's
really about which is a nice way of
saying swinging a Miss kid and I kept
giving him answers and he kept saying
what do you think it's really about and
then eventually he took mercy on me he
changed the subject something I could do
we talked for a while and we were done
and then we were going to meet the next
day and my plan was first time in London
in American in London I was going to go
get into trouble and see the sites but
no went back to my hotel room and called
everyone I knew in La like what's he
asking me what do I answer I don't want
to get fired and someone uh uh was
married to a professional writer and she
was nice enough to get on the phone with
me and explain what Ridley was
asking and and I'll get to this a little
bit so then I had to figure out what
what he's asking is at its core what is
the one thing the unifying thing that
everything is about and I will continue
the Really Scott story in a moment but I
just want to impress upon everyone
listening how important this is because
I wouldn't have known this I hadn't gone
through this ordeal and now on the other
side of working with writers it it's
just really clear that really smart
writers don't get this until it's
explained to them it's not it's just not
intuitively obvious so I want you to
imagine a really crazy story it's going
to take a few minutes but stay with me
because it's really
important imagine that you have a friend
who wants to be a professional home
builder and they have to write or build
a spec home like you have to write a
spec script and sell it or at least get
someone to see their spec home and say
you're amazing I'm going to hire you to
build a home for me okay and let's say
that you know land is really expensive
but they inherited this little Island so
they could build anywhere for free but
they only have enough money to buy
enough lumber and supplies to build one
house so they can only build one house
they take you to the island and they say
where should I build it should I build a
beach house should I build a forest
house should I build a mountain house
over I only have one shot I got to sell
this house where do I build it and you
say I think those are all great options
you can't go wrong with any of those and
they're like I know but what's the best
you're like they're all the best just
pick one and build it you're going to be
great you run into your friend a few
years later they're just like ah I am no
good at home building I couldn't get a
real estate agent I couldn't this I suck
and you're like no no you have so much
talent and they're like no I suck and
you're like can I see the house and
they're like you don't want to see the
house it's it's embarrassing I'm like no
no I want to see the house and they're
like all right say take you to the
island now this is where the story gets
crazy but this is the important
part imagine that your friend for some
crazy reason just couldn't decide where
to build the house so they built part of
it in the forest part of in the beach
and part of it they only had enough
supplies for one house so it's just
piles of rubble you know part of a wall
part of a this part of so it's like pile
of rubble over here pile of rubble over
here pile of rubble over here no one
wanted to buy a pile of rubble no one
looked at that pile of rubble and said
oh you're the person I want to give all
my money to to build a house for me this
is what Writers Do all the time they go
wide they don't go deep what is your
story about what is the singular thing
the singular unifying experience that
everything is built on writers will
build part of their story on this and
part of it on this part of it on this
and if your story is about more than one
thing it's not about
anything it's not a novel it's a
screenplay it's a pilot script it's got
to be a deep exploration of one
experience what is that experience it is
the most important question that you can
ask um I think the best screenplay ever
written
is network and it was written by Patty C
and I'm saying Patty c not to be cool or
hip but I am dyslexic and there's some
names I can't pronounce and I can't
pronounce Patty's last name and I feel
bad because I butcher it so when I say
Patty c not trying to be cool I just
can't pronounce his last name um I saw a
video where he said I feel sorry for the
writer who doesn't know what their story
is about and he would not write until he
knew what it was about and it took them
a year to figure out what network was
about which is a question how do you
live your life when you live in a
society that doesn't value human life
and everything in network is a is
reflection of that and a meditation on
that and built on that and it creates
that magic cohesion and it creates that
deep emotional impact and once he knew
what it was how do you live your life
when you live in a a society that no
longer values human life he typed it on
an index card and he put it above his
typewriter and it was a North
star uh I I trained someone who went on
to work on madman same thing uh Matthew
weer had the what's it about on the wall
so they would always navigate toward it
for Madmen what it was about was the
inherent conflict between that which you
most want to do and that which you need
to do so what you need to do but what
you want to do that inherent conflict in
everything in Mad Men every
storyline and subplot and charact it was
all built on that so people came in and
they would pitch like okay season 3 what
are possible storylines and you go
around the room remember throw out all
these ideas there'd be great ideas that
didn't sit on that piece of land so it
wouldn't be used it's so important a TV
show to have a cohesive deep experience
even if you don't know consciously what
it is like I've seen Network five times
and before that interview I never said
oh I love Netflix or Netflix no I don't
love Netflix I love Network um what a
brilliant meditation and exploration on
that inherent uh question of how do you
live your life when you live in society
that no longer values human life I
didn't see that consciously I did but
Patty did and once I heard Patty say
that on a video obviously since past I
went back and read the script and
watched the movie and I was like oh my
God
everything I was in Santa Monica at the
AO theater uh watching one of my
favorite 70s film um Dog Day Afternoon
and Frank Pearson the writer amazing
writer was there this a few years before
he passed away and he did questions and
someone asked him like what his writing
process was so this was this is really
um if you're at all interested in
writing you should really remember this
so what happened with that project is he
had four months to write a draft and
there going to give it to Al Pacino and
Al Pacino would read that draft and say
yes I'm going to make this movie or no
I'm not and they weren't going to go to
anyone else so it was one shot Al
paccino and this thing that uh Frank had
been working on for so long he had one
shot and so he had four months to write
the best possible script and someone was
like what did you do and he said well I
spent three months figuring out what the
story was singularly about and one month
writing it that tells you you something
that the best writers use 75% of his
scarce time to figure this out now once
you know what it's about it's your best
friend and your worst enemy so with
Ridley
Scott every day I kept coming in and I
knew what he was asking but I couldn't
get the answer it's hard and it seemed
like months of torture but it was like
five days and I finally said something
he's like write that down okay write
that down he goes read repeat it back to
me and I did he'll change this word cuz
Precision matters and he kept having me
refine it and he looked around the room
he goes read it again looked around the
room read it again looked around the
room he said will you do me a favor and
circle it oh it's circled Ridley he goes
that's what it's about and I was like
wow I just survived my first Gauntlet
and everything had to be built on that
and here's why it's your worst
enemy we once we knew it was
about we were really cruising and we
have almost the whole structure but we
could never come up with a great opening
we had okay openings but we all felt
like we didn't have an opening and one
day rley comes in with a skip and a step
and he's like have you ever seen Blade
Runner and I didn't tell him this but uh
I got fired for the first and only time
because of Blade Runner so when I was a
kid I lied about my age pretending to be
older so like I work in a movie theater
and it was an old dollar movie house
which they used to have and I was an
usher so my job was to sweep and do
ushery stuff and what I did is I'd come
in and I'd sweep into the theater
showing Blade Runner and then I'd sit
there for eight hours and then I'd sweep
my way to the time card and go home and
about three weeks later the manager said
Mandel my office want to talk to you and
I'm like okay Mr I forget his name but
anyway so I walk in in the office and he
goes have a seat and I do he goes it
appears to me that I'm paying you to
watch Blade Runner every day is this
true and I'm like yeah basically and he
goes why am I paying you to do that and
I'm like I don't know and he goes you're
fired and I'm like yeah I get it so like
I get it so yes I'm a fan of Blade
Runner but I didn't want to look like a
weird Fanboy so I said I've seen it a
couple of times and he said so we had an
opening that we loved but we couldn't
afford it we were on a pretty limited
budget but for this movie we could do it
I think with an adjustment this is our
opening would you be open to me telling
you what this opening is like oh yes
rley I'm open to yes go ahead you know
let's hear it so he's pitching me this
opening I'm just writing it down and
it's brilliant it's so good and I'm I
have chills cuz I'm like my name's going
on this script and people going think I
figured this out but I didn't this is
just such a great opening why didn't I
think of this and then he's almost done
and he goes oh dang it now we can't use
it I'm like what what we can't use it
what do you mean we can't use it we
can't use it I'm like really this is
awesome he yeah but it's not connected
to the what's it about and I wanted to
say you know F the what's it about like
but he had Artistic integrity like
everything so when you don't know what
your story is about you're just
groping in the darkness trying to figure
out what your story is and what belongs
or what doesn't once you know what it's
about you're going downhill in sunlight
and the light is just and the breeze and
that's great but then you're going to be
tested because you're going to have some
problem with your script something
you're stuck with and you're going to
finally have a great solution but
doesn't connect to what it's about and
then the question is do you have
Artistic integrity or not so it's your
best friend and it's your worst enemy um
now people will ask is this the same
thing as a log line no a log line is a
selling tool so Vince Gilligan's log
line for Breaking Bad was it's Mr Chips
goes it's Mr Chips goes to um no no I'm
sorry it's um yeah it's Mr Chips become
Scarface it's Mr Chips become Scarface
now that's an interesting idea Mr Chips
become Scarface tell me more let me read
the script it's interesting that's what
a log line does it can't be what it's
about because not everything is that's
the Walter White Journey that change but
what about Skyler what about Saul what
about all the other characters like that
can't be what it's about
no uh Vince Gilligan very slightly and
smartly tells you what it's about in the
second scene and the second scene of the
pilot Walter White is talking to his
chemistry class and he says what is
chemistry and he says it's the some
scientific ionic bonds and this and that
he goes but that's not what it's about
to me and he looks into the camera he
says this is what it's about to me it's
about the study of change that's what
the whole show is about that was the
what's it about for the entire show so I
remember uh a couple years ago I got a
call uh from a student she was just so
excited and impressed she was working at
Warner Brothers and she was a creative
executive and she got invited to some
meetings uh that the head of Warner
Brothers was taking with very big
writers and she called me and she goes I
didn't know that the head of Warner
Brothers was your student and I'm like I
don't think they were she goes no they
were your student I'm like I don't think
so and well then they're stealing your
stuff and I'm like okay what's going on
what happen I'm in this room and and
he's having these means with the big
writers and he's always asking them
what's it about and if they give an
answer that's not one thing is no no no
it's about more than one thing it's not
about anything so if if he didn't teach
you that if you if you didn't teach him
that you know he stole that from you I'm
like whoa whoa whoa whoa no I I stole it
from them like I'm teaching what the
industry does the industry is not doing
what I'm teaching I learned this from
Ridley Scott and it's so so important
that you know what your story is about
and it's a singular thing and then you
go deep and you connect everything to it
that is absolutely required if you want
to have any chance of anyone in the
industry paying attention to either your
pitch or your
script